freedom and banking this should not be
politicized Caitlyn long wants to start
a new kind of Bank a 100 percent Reserve
Bank that would keep all of our cash at
the FED in March of 2023 when rumors
started circulating on Twitter that
Silicon Valley Bank might be in trouble
it's panicked customers withdrew 42
billion dollars from their accounts in a
single day leaving it with a negative
cash balance in short order Regulators
shut it down a loss of over one billion
dollars there were fears of a run on
this bank it was a classic run on the
bank which is the phenomenon that's only
possible because of a standard practice
known as fractional Reserve banking in
which the money in your account isn't
actually sitting in your account
the money bank's hold for you is mostly
loaned out or invested they need to make
sure that they have enough cash on hand
to cover any withdrawals the system
works fine until there's a panic and
everyone comes for their money all at
once the libertarian Economist Murray
rothbard saw fractional Reserve banking
as a shell game and a Ponzi scheme
arguing that Banks should work exactly
like safety deposit boxes or money
warehouses required to keep all of their
customers money on hand at all times
and that's exactly what long has set out
to do the concept here is let's just
turn this into a basic money Warehouse
to the maximum extent possible within
within the law long who has a law degree
from Harvard and a public policy degree
from the Kennedy School of government
had a conventional career on Wall Street
working at Morgan Stanley Credit Suisse
and Solomon Brothers then came the 2008
financial crisis she thought all of the
standard accounts explaining the
Meltdown fell short in search of a
better framework she discovered the
Austrian School of economics and
rothbard
a lot more
people recognize that the money in their
bank is an IOU to a leveraged
institution most people didn't think
about that until recently so she founded
Wyoming based custodia bank which will
hold 108 percent of its customer
deposits in cash at all times serving as
a true Roth Guardian money warehouse but
there's a problem in January the Federal
Reserve board denied its application for
a master fed account which would allow
them to store cash and transact using
fed payment rails like every other major
bank custodia has sued the FED to force
it to reverse that decision they're
basically creating a federal veto that
has never in the history of the United
States existed and what I'm standing up
for and saying is that it shouldn't be
politicized period recent sat down with
long at the Bitcoin National Conference
in Miami to talk about her case against
the FED why she believes in full Reserve
banking the instability of our financial
system and why custodia could help
Bitcoin go mainstream
what is custodia Bank why did you start
it well it started it to
solve a couple of problems in the
industry one is a non-fractional bank
that will not create fractional interest
in Bitcoin and not rehypothecate Bitcoin
to use the the Big Wall Street term that
essentially means fractional Reserve
banking on something other than money uh
and then also not a fractional Reserve
Bank in money uh the proposal was to be
a 100 percent Reserve Bank that would
keep all of our cash at the Fed so just
uh basically a Pure service provider in
the sense that some banks were at one
time money warehouses uh where where
they were gold depositories that issued
gold receipts and some in some cases
those gold receipts circulated at par uh
and so the the the point is that some
banks were viewed as more honest than
others and the honest the dishonest
Banks had Bank runs and failed uh and
the way the U.S went went was to put the
deposit Insurance into place in 1933 but
if you look at the history there were
many attempts to put Deposit Insurance
in place before that to try to stem
these bank failures from the dishonest
Banks but there were honest Banks all
along and and so this is a nod to those
honest banks that were really just
service providers there's no reason why
your bank needs to be a counterparty
there's no reason why you have to have
an IOU it's just like the the law of
bailment which is how a valet parking
garage works or a code check when you
park your car you're not turning legal
title to your car over to the garage and
if the garage happens to go bankrupt
while your car is parked there you can
still get your key and drive your car
away that's not how Securities custody
works it's not how banking works you are
forced into becoming a counterparty you
are forced into turning title to your to
your property over to your financial
institution and if your financial
institution goes bus you may or may not
be able to get it back so the concept
here is let's just turn this into a
basic money Warehouse to the maximum
extent possible within within the law
and and have a nod to satoshi's Vision
Satoshi issued money that is no one's
IOU and there's no reason why your bank
or your securities broker has to give
you an IOU it's just the way the system
evolves but let's go back to the old
first principles of being a a
safeguarding entity that doesn't take
title to your property my understanding
is that your primary customers would be
large companies that hold a lot of
crypto assets why would they choose to
store their money at your bank rather
than somewhere else so our proposal has
always been just Bitcoin and ethereum so
not crypto broadly and the only reason
interestingly that we proposed ethereum
is because we had proposed and this was
turned down by the FED to issue a
digital Dollar on liquid which is a side
chain of Bitcoin and as a risk
management matter we we needed to have a
backup in case there was a failure of
the blockchain from an I.T risk
perspective you need to be able to to to
essentially take all the tokens that
were issued on one protocol and uh and
reissue them on another if if the
protocols failed let let's be honest
this is still relatively new technology
and it's not guaranteed that someone
won't find a zero day exploit in these
protocols they're getting Bitcoin and
ethereum are getting pretty mature but
it's still possible every day it goes
down you know asymptotically but it
never reaches zero probability that
someone finds a zero day exploit so it
was really a risk management matter that
we wanted to have too but of course
really primarily Bitcoin and uh we we're
going to start with that now what's
different about custodia the Wyoming law
where we're a Wyoming Chartered Bank the
Wyoming law which which if we can that
will be limited in in some states uh so
we won't be able to do business in all
50 states uh initially but
um to the extent that the Wyoming law
can apply to the custody relationship
here's the point remember I described
what a bailment is where it's the law of
valet parking or a coat check you're not
turning over title to your property that
does not exist in custody in the United
States right now no one can give a
bailment unless they're a Wyoming entity
moreover because custodia is a bank
in the event of the failure of the bank
you see what's happening there is a
receivership process that the bank
Regulators step in and provide the
receivership on it does not go through
U.S bankruptcy court this is going to
get a little esoteric but but I think
it's an important point a bankruptcy
judge in bankruptcy court can break a
contract so you can put your Bitcoin in
a trust company and the trust company
says well we'll segregate your assets
and of course they do but if the trust
company goes bankrupt and they're in
front of a bankruptcy judge and there
are not enough assets to pay out
everybody guess what those assets might
get pooled and you might take a haircut
whereas in a Wyoming
bank that is subject to these special
receivership rules the the statutory
segregation the segregation of assets
rather is is protected by Statute and a
judge first of all there won't be a
bankruptcy judge because there's a
special receivership statute so the
contracts cannot be broken if they're
protected by Statute but the uh the the
the the
Wyoming receiver is ultimately the bank
the bank Regulators ultimately the
receiver in the event of a of a failure
of the bank as opposed to a bankruptcy
judge two totally different processes
and here's the point if I if I ended up
going a little bit too deep there the
point is it's a it's a more
investor-friendly regime in Wyoming it's
a nod to satoshi's vision of what
Bitcoin was supposed to be now I am also
a a big proponent of not your keys not
your coins
a big proponent of that and so
a lot of folks have asked why are you a
big proponent of self-custody that that
you can't own Bitcoin through an
intermediary and safely count it as your
own Bitcoin versus now starting a
custodian how do you square that Circle
the answer is there are a lot of
businesses especially fiduciary
businesses like like SEC 40 act mutual
fund managers investment companies
registered investment advisors corporate
treasurers pension fund managers they
have fiduciary obligations and either by
Statute or by best practice they
segregate the management of the assets
from the custody of the assets this has
been the law in in the mutual fund and
registered investment advisor world
since 1940 to segregate the management
of the assets from the custody and so
this is a nod to that Marketplace that
we we're we're setting up a bank that is
designed to mirror as much as possible
the visual vision of outright property
right ownership you are not required to
turn over a legal title of your asset
into a Wyoming special purpose
depository institution custodian however
it is actually a private Key Management
Service so this is not something where
we would expect the customer to keep the
private key they are taking some risk of
course on the on the private Key
Management the insurance markets have
are not mature enough to ensure a
hundred percent of the value and so it's
Market practice that some percentage of
the value
is insured by an insurer and that's
ultimately the risk custodian is
providing the safe keeping services but
the legal title remains with the owner
so the main thing that would
differentiate you from an exchange like
coinbase let's say you have a lot of
Bitcoin you want to store it on you want
to have a custodian you want to have
coinbase or custodia Bank the main
difference there would be what happens
in the case of bankruptcy you go to the
bankruptcy court with coinbase you go to
straight to the Wyoming regulator if
custodia Bank were to fail and they
would have the investors back yeah and
the Wyoming law recognizes bailment no
other state in the United States
recognizes a bailment for for a digital
asset custody we're here at Bitcoin
Miami 2023
people have a lot of ideas about what
Bitcoin is what its value is what its
purpose is what's your answer to that
question what do you think the purpose
of Bitcoin is well Bitcoin has many
purposes but to me the simplest is the
most basic which is it's an honest
Ledger No One controls
The Ledger because everyone controls The
Ledger and
in terms of what is money to people why
do why do people save they want a store
of value that's honest and cannot be
manipulated and as a system Bitcoin is
anti-fragile we are learning that the
traditional Financial system is fragile
I would argue that it's been fragile all
along it's just that more people are
waking up to the issues so at at bottom
Bitcoin is simply an honest Ledger
and it's been a tumultuous year or so
for crypto as a whole
how do you think about Bitcoin in
particular in that context good riddance
to the vast majority of what happened in
crypto uh and in fact I I still think
there's a big chunk of crypto that needs
to burn on a raging funeral prior there
were criminals scammers grifters
over leveraged business models that
should never have been implemented and
it was a bubble no question and of
course Bitcoin got caught up in all that
and in fact actually in my last
interview with reason we were talking
about the financialization risks as
Bitcoin would become financialized it
would become fractionalized there would
be people who like for example FTX we
now know
took in U.S dollars and promised
Bitcoins back but didn't actually own
the Bitcoins so what did they do they
created more claims to bitcoin than
there were actual Bitcoins because they
gave people Bitcoin ious and yet didn't
have actual Bitcoins to back them up and
so we know that that it was getting
fractionalized and that had a big impact
on on the price it made it more volatile
it made the cost of capital go up for
every one of us in the industry who are
operators trying to provide services
around the protocol uh everybody's cost
of capital went up because it became a
lot more volatile it didn't uh it it
clipped the top off the off the the
price all the old models that predicted
that the peak of the bull market would
be a lot higher than it actually was I
think it is a function of the fact that
it got financialized and that uh that
suppresses the price but it also on the
downside cannot and in The Leverage
unwind can actually cause that leverage
flush to move the spot price even lower
so it's asymmetric you don't have as
much upside when you get a financialized
asset and the downside can be worse when
when you get the corrections and and
that happened I long for the days when
Bitcoin was not the hot thing and we had
a pure market and uh frankly there are
very few Financial assets if any in the
world that actually are pure markets so
those are the main factors that you see
as pushing bitcoin's price down at the
moment because you would expect one of
the propositions of Bitcoin is that it's
an inflation hedge you know when the
when the money printer goes Burr yeah
Bitcoin is there and now we've had the
money printer do that we have inflation
yet Bitcoin is flat or on a decline so
is that your explanation for that
Bitcoin has bounced pretty hard off the
bottom it's actually one of the best
performing asset classes this year and
of course it's very volatile peaked a
trough I never give investment advice
but uh it it I think the bottom is
probably in it's hard to say uh for sure
I mean there are certainly a lot of
things stacked up against it but we're
heading into another happening so yes
the leverage unwind no no doubt and the
Damage that was done by the the
criminals uh they still they still need
to get flushed and most of crypto I
actually agree with the with the the
critics most of this is just scams and
and ultimately will go away but for
those of us who lived in the.com bubble
frankly it's repeating a lot of of those
businesses never turned a profit much
less were cash flow positive and they
ended up getting flushed and markets
work and boy did markets work here
that fractionalization that you were
talking about being the prob one the
primary problem with FTX that it was
just
saying it had all these reserves and
really didn't correct is what your bank
is designed to fix looking through your
proposal and the federal reserve's
response to that proposal it looked like
you're you your plan is to start off
with a hundred eight percent of reserves
in cash how would that affect the the
security of someone's investment right
well actually our proposal was to keep a
hundred percent of it in cash at all
times okay at the FED I I'm interested
in Fortress balance sheet not interested
in taking investment risk this is not a
yield play this was always a fee-based
business model a service provider so a
lot of fintechs make a lot of money
charging fees to their customers and not
earning an interest spread the interest
spread is where the risk starts to come
into the banking business as you know
and so if you could have a fee-based
Bank it will never be the low-cost
provider but the design is to have a
fortress balance sheet before we get
into the your battle with the Federal
Reserve let's talk a little bit more
about Wyoming the governor appointed you
back in 2018 to head up the Wyoming
blockchain task force which the state
legislature created to advise on crypto
regulation so that board made a number
of recommendations and the legislature
ended up passing 13 different crypto
laws what were the most important laws
to come out of that process that makes
Wyoming a particularly appealing place
for crypto for Bitcoin right it actually
kept going they're up to something like
33 laws now because they turned it from
a task force into a select committee
what Wyoming did was very simple basic
stuff that I know the reason audience
cares a lot about Wyoming to find
digital assets as property
and so if it's stolen then you know
theft laws apply for example but
moreover it it also defined the legal
rights and obligations of parties to
commercial transactions involving
digital assets and you may wonder why
anyone cares about that Bitcoin itself
is it exists in a vacuum it doesn't have
any nod to any legal system anywhere the
code itself just runs and it runs in all
legal systems all around the United
States or all around the world right now
but the issue that we spotted is that
none of us lives in a in a vacuum right
everyone lives in a place where there is
some rule of law and unless you live on
a seastead right you're you're not in a
in a completely libertarian Utopia so
the law itself could be an attack Vector
on bitcoin holders and this is a I have
to give a nod to trace Mayer Who was one
of the original Bitcoin ogs so to speak
who who understood this this would
eventually become an attack Vector that
you would have have courts coming after
people for their Bitcoin in divorce
situations or in
um you know if the government decides
that they don't is it that they want to
confiscate it right FDR's confiscation
of gold that absolutely could happen so
how do we get ahead of that how do we
make sure that the technology is
so-called backwards compatible with the
legal system was one of the questions
okay so this is foundational boring
stuff but those are ultimately the most
important things Wyoming did and they
ended up leading the rest of the United
States there's now been a proposal
albeit a controversial one in a couple
of red states to recognize controllable
electronic records as a digital asset
now this would be Beyond just crypto
this is anything that is in digital form
for decades we've actually just been
sort of band-aiding the commercial law
system in the United States which was
written for everything to be in paper
this is why when you get a check you now
have to take a picture of it that is
deemed to be the paper version so
instead of just you know instead of
everything just being electronic there
still has to be some sort of there's an
analog paper version of it and they'll
accept it if it's a photograph it's
crazy that's all designed to be able to
comply with these old laws that required
for everything to be in writing and then
about 20 years ago the uniform
electronic transactions Act uwida was
passed that that was a Band-Aid it just
was an appendix that basically said all
right certain things can be in digital
form but we needed to go to a
recognition that some assets will never
be an analog form they will be natively
digital at issue and that's what a
digital asset is and so it didn't really
fit within the legal structure and
ultimately what this means is that the
rest of the United States followed suit
now they went a little further than
Wyoming Wyoming recognized that Bitcoin
itself can be money under commercial law
but you might have seen this has become
a hot potato in in South Dakota Florida
and Texas and Alabama I believe there
are a few other states now that are
getting on this bandwagon of we don't
want to recognize a central bank digital
currency in our commercial law right and
the way that the National Committee
wrote this it did it did foretell that
eventually there would be digital
dollars and digital Yuan and digital
there already is you did a digital you
want but digital Yen and digital Swiss
Francs right and so there was a
recognition that there would be Central
Bank issued money in digital form and at
that point uh you started to see the the
politics enter And The anti-cbdc Crowd
by the way I'm very anti-cbdc but I
think vetoing that particular provision
of the legislation doesn't stop a cbdc
is there a way to separate the cbdc
component and just protect things like
Bitcoin
is that
um something that do you think will be
scaled up to the federal level
ultimately the cbdc thing is a hot
potato and it may indeed be one of the
reasons why the Federal Reserve uh shot
a bazooka at at a bunny rabbit in in how
it treated custodia because custodia had
proposed to issue a digital dollar it
would have been a bank issued digital
dollar not going back to the Wildcat
banking era where there would have been
a custodia dollar it would have been a
actual dollar issued by a bank just like
any sort of instrument like a check uh
those are ultimately negotiable for
dollars so a pure dollar just issued on
a different payment rail not fed wire or
ACH but uh custodia actually was granted
last July the patent on a bank taking in
a U.S dollar deposit and issuing a token
against it and so there's some thought
that maybe the the the the FED not only
didn't like the idea of a bank doing
this but that because the the regional
federal reserve banks are private
entities if this If the Fed ever wanted
to issue a cbdc and somebody had a
patent on a bank taking in a U.S dollar
deposit and issuing a token against it
that that might actually get in the way
so this digital dollar which is called
Avid uh what the Federal Reserve had to
say about that in denying your
application was that it could possibly
become a tool for persons around the
world to access the stability of the US
dollar instantly and anonymously and by
setting a precedent for tools like that
to be used by other Banks create a new
meaningful and volatile source of demand
for Federal Reserve liabilities is there
concern that Avid is a threat to the
Integrity of the Federal Reserve System
and the stability and the volatility a
sound well it's their concern but I
think what they ought to do is take a
look at what the market is actually
doing look at tether look at usdc look
at the demand for these uh there are
real transactions admittedly most of
that of most of the volume is
speculative but there are real world
uses of these new payment rails so I
mean it's so funny you go back and look
at the the history of the fed the faster
payments initiative I recall was around
in 2016 and here we are in 2023 coming
out they're coming out with their new
payment rail called fednow I mean a few
Engineers got together and created
tether and look at what it turned itself
into without any permission it's a new
payment Rail and so absolutely is that
something that uh that the fed's not
happy about sure they've made that
Crystal Clear they only want themselves
and regulated Banks to be issuing US
Dollars however this what what we
brought to the Fed was a proposal to do
just that be a regulated bank that
issues US Dollars and get this into the
so-called regulatory perimeter you see
Federal Reserve Governors all the time
complaining that Financial technology
companies that are not licensed as Banks
and therefore not subjects of Bank
capital and Bank supervision are issue
are doing certain things in in the
financial industry and they keep saying
that they want them to come into the
regulatory perimeter so when one
actually tried they they rebuffed us in
a nasty way how would they ensure that a
bank issuing a digital dollar would not
be fractionalizing those digital dollars
and I mean we've already seen other
stable coins lose their tether to the US
dollar dropping in value what do you do
about that well this is why having a
bank that was sitting 100 in cash plus
the extra eight percent you alluded to
earlier was our shareholders Equity so
literally put all of the assets of the
company other than you know intangibles
and furniture or office furniture those
sorts of things uh all the financial
assets of the company would have been in
in our fed master account that's how you
how the proposal was to ensure that it
never sort of broke the box so to speak
unlike what we've seen with the
algorithmic stable coins which certainly
have and then the ones that are backed
by that are asset backed basically which
is which is the proposal that custodia
made regarding Abbott you know they've
not traded it exactly one dollar we just
saw the example when Silicon Valley Bank
failed one of the one of the parties
that got bailed out let's be honest was
a crypto company called Circle because
they had their deposits at Silicon
Valley Bank and it worked out that about
12 cents of their deposit of every
dollar of deposit of every every USD DC
stable coin was at Silicon Valley Bank
and guess what the market did very
swiftly started trading usdc at 88 cents
on the dollar once they disclosed 12
cents of their reserves were at Silicon
Valley Bank on the weekend of a bank run
and then as soon as Silicon Valley Bank
got bailed out and all the uninsured
deposit holders including this circle
Reserve holders got bailed out lo and
behold it went right back to a dollar
again so markets work let's talk about
then the denial of your application
which happened on January 27th of this
year after two years of waiting to get
that master account right what was your
reaction
to getting that projection if we were
blindsided we had been making a lot of
progress with the fed and then something
clearly changed and why were you seeking
a master account in with the uh Federal
Reserve what would that allow you to do
to be able to keep cash directly at the
FED like any depository institution
federal law says the Federal Reserve
shall provide services
to depository institutions either an
insured depository institution or a
depository institution eligible to apply
so essentially an FDIC insured bank or a
bank that's eligible to apply for FDIC
insurance we actually did apply for FDIC
insurance and they were not interested
in anything related to digital assets
and candidly as I've said before I agree
with them and here's why we saw how fast
the money can move in in the digital
asset world the traditional banking
system is not set up for that yet I mean
holy cow just online banking movement is
enough to take down a bank in today's
day and age when you get crypto which
moves so much faster than traditional
payment rails so an ethereum transaction
will settle in three minutes a Bitcoin
transaction in 10 minutes
ACH can take up to three days fed wire
you can do it in hours but you can't
program it you can't use software to
direct direct it and you'll never know
exactly when it's going to settle so now
you're talking about all these
settlement mismatches
and if the trade doesn't settle
simultaneously for both parties
somebody's carrying an un
uninsured counterparty credit risk so I
started warning about this in fact
actually the Cato my Cato Institute
monetary conference keynote in 2020 I
talked about how dangerous it was to
have the the stable coin issuers holding
Reserves at fractional reserve banks
that it was going to cause a bank run
and uh sure enough the bank run came it
wasn't because of mass withdrawals from
stable coins it was for diff which is
just plain online banking so I didn't
disagree with the denial on FDIC
insurance for that reason so without
that FDIC Insurance why would an
investor want to put their money in your
bank wouldn't they be afraid ah well the
whole idea again is that this is back to
back to the Federal Reserve so actually
the opposite was that I think the
Federal Reserve was more concerned that
it would be too safe why would they be
afraid that it's too safe if a bank is
too safe it's not welcome because we
need to
we need to pigeonhole everybody into the
banking system that isn't really safe
fractional Reserve banking has always
been fundamentally unstable it's go back
to It's a Wonderful Life right where's
your deposit it's in Joey's car and it's
in you know uh Jimmy's house right
because the bank has a length of money
it's always been that way it's
fundamentally unstable and it's
fundamentally a confidence game that
relies on the assumption that not
everybody will go withdraw their
deposits at the same time when you get a
bank run which is what has happened to
some of these Banks recently because
information travels at the speed of
light that old bottle of borrowing short
term and lending long term which is what
the banks do it just doesn't work
anymore and now we're speeding up the
the speed of Bank runs not just to
online banking speed but with fed now
coming online this year in July can you
imagine what the Silicon Valley Bank
bank bank run weekend would have looked
like
if everybody had had 24 7 365 access
Silicon Valley Bank lost 25 percent of
their deposits in the span of four hours
that would have kept going that night
and over that weekend so uh here's the
punch line banks are massively under
liquid they're going to have to hold a
lot more cash because their liabilities
turn over a lot faster than anyone has
ever realized they could you believe
that part of the reason they denied this
is because to allow it would be to
expose or wake people up to the
weaknesses of the current fractional
Reserve System and they would flock to a
safer Bank
well that sir is one interpretation
there's been a lot of discussion among
macro analysts that I read for example
like Lynn Alden saying the the FED can
never acknowledge that the system in
aggregate is insolvent because it will
just trigger a bank run immediately but
by the way this is not new this has been
this way all along it's just that more
people are waking up to it because
social media and you're not you're not
there's a lot more free movement of
information and it moves at the speed of
light now so there's a debate within
libertarian circles about fractional
Reserve banking right now we're existing
in a world where we've got a central
bank there's the libertarian world where
there is no Central Bank there's just
competing Banks and on one end of Free
banking on one end of the spectrum
there's people like Murray rothbard who
said fractional reserve banks are fraud
they should they cannot should not exist
in a free Society on the other other end
you've got people like George selgan who
says that actually in a free banking
system fractional Reserve Banks would
exist and they have a legitimate reason
for existing they can supply the money
or the credit to meet demand especially
in you know uh recession type
environments where along that Spectrum
do you fall I guess philosophically oh
much closer to rothbard I started as a
free banker and then pretty quickly
realized any time you create anything
out of thin air it creates a distortion
in the market price this is the
distinction between commodity credit and
circulation credit that mises wrote
about a commodity credit is is debt that
is backed up by prior savings nobody
created any credit out of thin air in
the Free banking world you will have
credit created out of thin air and
ultimately that that distorts the price
of credit in the marketplace and that's
the bigger issue
so I I ended up evolving very very
strongly towards the the rothbardian
side of of things and now with the world
I just described where transactions are
settling even faster
that fractional Reserve or Free banking
model is inherently more unstable
because if there's going to be any
maturity transformation where the bank
takes the deposit in short term and
lends it long term that bank is
inherently insolvent when everyone comes
and gets their money back it's done
so how is credit generated in that world
great question here's if we were
starting all over again and we wanted to
get to a truly digital natively digital
and fair system what would we do we
would have Pension funds make long-term
loans like mortgages and and the like
because Pension funds are long-term
money we would very carefully duration
match there's a long-term bar of demand
for a long-term loan it should be
provided by a long-term saver like a
pension fund I cut my teeth in my Wall
Street career on the life insurance and
and annuities and pensions businesses
those are the longest term right you're
you know somebody's buying life
insurance in their in their 20s because
or 30s because they have a child their
life expectancy is still probably 50 60
years right and so the cash flows on
something like that are super long term
and what you need to do is find super
long-term Investments to invest against
that and the opposite is true on the
annuities world with annuities you're
basically paying out somebody or a
pension fund you're paying out somebody
a monthly payment for the rest of their
lives beginning typically at age 65 the
duration of that could be 20 years now
with banks you're dealing with a low a
shorter duration business mix right you
tend to be yeah sure there may be some
30-year mortgages in there but mostly
it's going to be student loans or credit
cards right and so having cut my teeth
in things that are 20 to 50 year
duration and then coming into the
banking world where you're looking at
the maturity mismatches of two to five
years it was so clear to me you just
never want to have an asset liability
mismatch so here's the point back to
your question how do you how is credit
created it's created on an asset
liability matched basis but we have to
get out of the crazy regulatory regime
that prevents that right now right now
the crazy regulatory regime tells the
banks take in a demand deposit and make
a 30-year mortgage loan and it tells the
Pension funds go buy stocks would the
let the solution be to make it so if
you're a bank to get a bank Charter you
are not allowed to make those kinds of
loans correct that's the Wyoming Speedy
structure okay it's a non-lending
charter by the way Wyoming is not alone
there are five states that have
uninsured Bank charters in the United
States there is no reason why you
fundamentally need to have a bank
borrowing short-term and lending
long-term markets can clear
and the only reason why
that exists right now is because of the
Central Banking structure that that
guarantees it
so the rationale that the Federal
Reserve board gave for denying your
truck your application was that your
novel business model and proposed
focused on Chris crypto assets are
highly likely to be inconsistent with
safe and sound banking practices what is
your reaction to the idea that because
your bank has
Bitcoin and ethereum that it's just too
risky to integrate into the system
um I I think that's a hilarious
statement keep in mind the Bitcoin and
ethereum were all in assets under
custody not on the bank's balance sheet
what was the bank's balance sheet it was
proposed to be a hundred percent
invested in cash on deposit at the FED
as vanilla and boring as it possibly
could be now the Federal Reserve very
clearly is not interested they joined
the the all of government Crackdown that
the bite Administration the Biden White
House started on crypto so that is them
saying they do not like crypto and they
do admit that you have the capital on
hand to run a full Reserve Bank for now
um but they worry won't be solvent in
the future because they say they would
never approve a bank that has your
business model for making money partly
off crypto fees so it's kind of a
catch-22 with what they're putting there
why should the FED allow this sort of
Orthodox model into the system just
given the uncertainty so let's get back
to
is crypto going away what the Biden
White House has chosen to do is hope
that it goes away we don't want anybody
including the big Banks big companies
like coinbase right they're every one of
the U.S service providers in this
industry has had a regulatory action
against them in the last few months it's
part of an olive government approach
okay so they just want it to go away
well when it doesn't go away what next
okay what they've now done is shove it
offshore businesses are still going to
get their US dollar Services they're
just going to get it from non-us Banks
so we just saw a bank in Gibraltar that
is offering US dollar
is basically the same business model as
custodia now what's the impact of that
to the FED they're going to be playing
whack-a-mole for the next several years
as risks come back into the U.S in
places they don't expect it can't
measure have no visibility yeah it would
have been better again remember we
started at the beginning with them
saying all of this needs to be in the
regulatory perimeter and all these
companies need to come get Bank Charters
and get licensed as Banks and get
federally regulated and then when one of
them came and said we are willing to do
all of that Not only was it proverbially
shot it was done in a in a nasty way
including some very nasty press leaks
obviously a lot of this nervousness
around crypto in general is coming in
the wake of the FTX melted absolutely
what do you think are the big lessons to
take away from FTX meltdown well that
was out allegedly outright Criminal
right so what's the big lesson from that
unfortunately greed and greed exists and
uh people can get taken in by fraudsters
I think you know uh from uh from the
interview that I uh on stage that I did
with Sam begman Freed at this conference
Bitcoin 2021 two years ago uh where I
was pretty clear uh that that I knew his
business model was going to fail and he
and I were arguing over whether leverage
was good leverage is never good in
crypto period all of those crypto
lenders I knew were going to fail why
because there's a finite number of
Bitcoin all you're doing is creating
fractional Reserve Bitcoin and that's
all going to come back to haunt you when
inevitably there's going to be a price
correction and everybody wants the real
thing and then those those lenders that
were running fractional go bust now we
saw all of those and that absolutely
happened in the case of FTX it does
appear from the the bankruptcy filings
but on top of that that there was
outright fraud
you post allegedly
you published a Twitter thread
um that in February disclosing that you
handed over evidence to law enforcement
of probable crimes committed by a big
crypto fraud starting months before that
company imploded yes can you say more
about that tweet not much more I I I
will say that uh that law enforcement is
doing its job and
um did come back and ask for ask for
more and I had access to more it was not
evidence that I gleaned myself it was
someone who came to me who was a
participant in some of the private chat
rooms saw illegal activity took
snapshots of it in that same thread he
said that it is not partisan to clean up
crypto fraud it's the right thing to do
correct are you advocating for more
regulation of the crypto industry well a
lot of the laws already exist they
should be enforced
so this gets back to the question we
were just talking about is this better
to be in the regulatory perimeter or is
it better to be shoved offshore where
there's even more fraud because scammers
can like by the way sandbagment free to
FTX went offshore for a reason
he would never have qualified for a
Wyoming Bank Charter right so keep in
mind this was an offshore end today
that's where the vast majority of the
activity took place and they did not
have the the regulatory oversight nor
did they have laws they had to comply
with that prevented the the the outcome
that that occurred where they were
running fractional it seems like your
project is in many ways to make Bitcoin
play better with the state and vice
versa whether that's the state of
Wyoming or the Federal Reserve System
Bitcoin grew out of the cypherpunk
movement and there's people from that
movement who believe it should just be a
completely parallel system and have
nothing to do with the state yeah how do
you reconcile those things well so I
think most even The Cypher punks the
hardest core Libertarians would say that
there is a role in government to enforce
private property rights okay the fraud
that occurred was an encroachment on
private property rights so there is
absolutely a role for law enforcement to
enforce the private property rights of
those who were scammed sure so I think
we can set that aside and and and
candidly I've been trying to clean up
this industry uh for for a while because
I firmly believe that there are affronts
to private property rights uh and
ultimately uh candidly I'm kind of happy
that AI has come along because I'm
watching a lot of the scammers go there
and a lot of them have left Bitcoin
putting aside FTX you know custodia Bank
really is uh would be a direct Bridge
from Bitcoin yes into the Federal
Reserve System yes why build that and
some of the Cypher punks don't think
it's necessary but here's here's where I
think it is and ultimately all of them
are still paying their employees and
their you know their rent and they're
maybe not their employees but certainly
their rent and their vendors and dollars
right they need access to dollar dollars
right so ultimately here's the issue
we're not ready for hyper bitcoinization
today I don't want to live in a world
where we have hyper bitcoinization today
because what does that imply it implies
the US dollar system imploded and all of
the things that came with that okay I do
believe the world will transition to
bitcoin but I'm much more likely I I
prefer a world where it's peaceful now I
would much rather build a bridge that
allows these two systems to to co-exist
without hurting each other there's a
very good argument that both systems
hurt each other because there was no
safe and sound bridge between the two
how worried are you that we're getting
close to that point where things are
just going to dissolve because we and
you know the other obviously background
to all this that we've talked a little
bit about earlier
are the bank failures Silicon Valley
Bank what is your analysis of the
current state of the banking system very
unhealthy right because on a mark to
Market basis again there's not Equity
there and that's acknowledged so you'll
hear the bank Regulators say the system
is safe and sound what's the difference
are they lying not really because
they're presuming that all of the
depositors won't show up and withdraw
their money at the same time and reveal
the extent of the insolvency but the the
world a lot a lot more people in the
world now recognize that the money in
their bank is an IOU to a leveraged
institution most people didn't think
about that until recently and oh boy on
social media especially the younger
Generations that makes them want Bitcoin
even more because it's something they
can own they can control I was just
talking to Dylan LeClaire today on on
our panel Dylan's never written a check
he has once set foot in a bank branch
okay so and again he's a different
generation because he never had to right
everything's digital so when they see
these things where the where we're
trying to all be pushed back into that
analog world they just roll their eyes
and say Ah that's Boomer stuff and and
they're not wrong yeah let's wrap up
with a brief discussion of the status of
the lawsuit how do you feel about how
things have proceeded so far in the
legal process well I can't comment uh
since we
custodia filed against both the Kansas
City Federal Reserve Bank in June of
2022. and I've seen you say that you
think it really is the Federal Reserve
board and maybe even some players above
them who is kind of pulling the strings
or managing things not the local branch
custodia applied for our Federal Reserve
master account in October 2020 right
after we got the bank Charter and a few
months later the a senior official at
the Kansas City fed said there were no
Show Stoppers and then all of a sudden
it all just stopped you alluded to the
allegation that it might have even come
from above yes at the in when our
membership application was denied
remember the membership application is
different than the master kind of
application two different applications
when the membership application was
denied there is no question the White
House was involved in that and part of
that was because of the press leaks I
alluded to earlier there were reporters
calling us today days before the Fed was
voting on our application telling us it
would be voted down and we subsequently
heard through the the the Grapevine in
Washington Everybody Talks there were
folks who knew what happened who came
forward and who gave us names and when I
went subsequently to the Congressional
oversight committees they were
interested in hearing what had happened
uh and when I shared what what I knew
they all knew it out already who was in
charge and who at the White House was
orchestrating this all of government
Crackdown on crypto
why the FED played ball with the White
House on that is a question I don't know
the answer to yet
what is at stake in this case beyond the
future of custodia Bank in a bigger
sense if we go back in the history of
the United States we have something
called the Dual banking system
historically States chartered all the
banks and then Lincoln created a federal
chartering Authority in 1863 with the
National Bank act a deal that got cut
was both the Federal Bank chartering
Authority and the State Bank chartering
authorities coexisted and they were they
had equal powers and then the Fed was
created in 1913
and then the FDIC in 1933 Congress did
not give either one of those agencies
the authority to Charter Banks it kept
the chartering Authority with the states
and with the federal agency called the
OCC the office of the Comptroller of the
currency so the chartering authorities
are made by those separate entities and
they are to have access to those
utilities that was not controversial
until about 10 years ago when operation
choke point came in and then you started
to see the FDIC starting to push certain
industries out of out of the banking
system and then the Federal Reserve
started to deny certain State chartered
Banks access to the payment system
what's at bottom here is a 10th
Amendment kind of approach it's it's it
does the Dual banking system still exist
or are these federal agencies who have
just voted themselves vetoes over State
chartering Decisions by saying no we
don't want these Banks FDIC insured no
we don't want these Banks to have
Federal payment system access they're
basically creating a federal veto that
has never in the history of the United
States existed banking just becomes
something that is at the federal level
or nationalized and states are just cut
out of it what worries you most about
that future well you see the control the
degree of control that the federal
government has tried to exert cleaning
up fraud is not political banking should
not be political either we should not be
using we collectively all the people
should not be using the banking system
as a political Hammer what I'm standing
up for and saying is that it shouldn't
be politicized period and so if this is
federalized what do you think happens to
a state like Texas with their oil and
gas industry what do you think happens
to Wyoming with oil and gas and and
firearms and and the like
right so I mean exactly where it the
fights that were happening we're seeing
just the federal power grabs everywhere
and so it is absolutely imperative for
states to defend their rights and I'm
not saying this is a red state blue
State thing I think all states need to
defend their rights because power
changes in Washington DC and we've seen
abuses on both sides especially in the
banking world it's been coming from the
left but I'm warning it absolutely
absolutely could come from the right
you're seeing these these um these these
efforts to ban Tick Tock for example
right and you know these these companies
start getting debanked in the United
States if you don't have a bank account
you are not a business there there needs
to be freedom in banking and one of the
interesting developments that I've seen
is that uh The Challengers if you will
in the in both political parties for
presidential uh for the presidential
race have come out in favor of freedom
them in banking Biden's obviously
cracking down on it and I've seen some
crackdowns from Trump as well but the
the but Kennedy on the Democrats and
DeSantis on the Republicans uh have both
come out pretty pretty hard in support
of Bitcoin and against Central Bank
digital currencies and against the
federal overreach in banking and that's
a wonderful thing I hope they can both
drag their the the the lead candidates
in both parties towards freedom and
banking this should not be politicized
Caitlyn long thank you very much for
talking with us thank you
thank you